okay why can't anything just go well for
Donald Trump why can't Donald Trump get
through any social situation or
encounter without completely
embarrassing himself and showing himself
to be completely and utterly out of
touch and I'm talking of course not of
Donald Trump's latest sexual encounter
with his wife which I'm sure was
incredibly awkward but that's not what
I'm talking about today I'm talking
about Donald Trump's Halloween Donald
Trump welcomed the kids of the White
House I guess it's the White House press
corps I don't know if it's the traveling
press or the press that is stationed at
the White House but some subsection of
the White House and presidential
covering press and producer Noah
Ferguson apprised me to this and it is
just amazing
no we're gonna play some clips believe
me folks no awareness of his
surroundings
no realization that these are kids they
happen to be the kids of press people
but that doesn't mean they know all
about the lying fake news media and all
of these other terms that Donald Trump
has been using now for over a year these
are children and Donald Trump seems to
not only have no awareness of that and
of how to talk to kids I imagine that
his conversations with Barron Trump must
be bizarre but he also gets absolutely
no basic pop cultural references here's
Donald Trump speaking to a kid who's
dressed as Darth Vader Darth Vader's the
costume of course Darth Vader the bad
guy from Star Wars and it is the father
of Luke Skywalker right or is that he is
the father of Luke Skywalker yes he's
the father of Luke Skywalker etc etc and
Donald Trump has no clue who Darth Vader
is take a look at this and we're gonna
take the picture of the Oval Office okay
wow that's that's just scary outfit so
who are you
that is it come on over here honey
come on right over here yeah Wow well
who are you Darth Vader wow that's
incredible
reminds me of when Mitt Romney couldn't
identify a chocolate doughnut maybe the
most out of touch moment of the entire
bromley presidential campaign reminder
if you missed that yeah that's a
doughnut mint have you ever heard of
that
then Trump goes into bad-mouthing the
parents of the kids which is a nice
touch because again these were the kids
of media people but most of these kids
don't know that Trump's been
bad-mouthing their parents for so long
and Trump starts bad-mouthing the
parents to the kids yeah and then Trump
makes a girl cry and then it comes up
this is this is probably the weirdest
this is probably the weirdest clip of
the entire thing
Trump makes a girl cry and then it comes
out that the girls Japanese and then it
gets really weird where Trump seems to
grimace after acknowledging that the
girl is Japanese and maybe the weirdest
interaction between a president than a
kid that we've ever seen you know they
media
which is Japanese you know that that's
beautiful these are beautiful wonderful
children the grimace on his face after
the girl says I know you're going to
Japan is like nothing I've seen before
and then Trump decides which kids are
thin enough to have candy telling one
girl that BAE I think it's a girl that
cheap because she doesn't have weight
problems she said she's allowed to have
candy in the white house Jade take a
look at this man then Trump makes a
weird political comment to a kid and
then congratulate the room for what
isn't immediately clear take a look
congratulations folks nobody gets it not
a single kid in the room knows what the
hell Trump is talking about you're
treated well by the press and then we
finally understand what it is
that Trump is congratulating the room
for he's congratulating the parents I
guess for being able to have produced
these children anyway well
congratulations folks you did a good job
yeah I wouldn't say you did very well
here but really just everything is so
cringeworthy ly awkward it reminds me of
when Trump welcomed people to the Easter
Egg Roll so the Easter Egg Roll is this
non-political longtime White House
tradition kids get to a search for
Easter they roll Easter eggs and I think
there's also an Easter egg hunt on the
White House lawn it's not political it's
just fun it's mostly for the kids and
Trump gives a political speech and if
you're not watching this one you're
gonna miss half of the optics because
Don Donald Trump gives up
clinical speech with the Easter Bunny
standing next to him take a look at this
and we will be stronger and bigger and
better as a nation than ever before
we're right on track you see what's
happening and we are right on track so
thank you everybody for being here yeah
next to the Easter Bunny and giving a
political speech you might as well have
Batman standing behind you when you
announced the next action against North
Korea what a bizarre bizarre event at
the White House yesterday and he just
can't be a normal person because he's
not he's he's so much more out of touch
even than Mitt Romney and I know you
know Mitt Romney had this amazing staged
event where he he went shopping at
Costco and all he bought was multiple
cases of seltzer water and Greek yogurt
like it was during the campaign against
Barack Obama it was such an obviously
fabricated moment where Mitt Romney
grabbed the shopping card and he just
filled it with just why did why do you
have so much seltzer you're traveling
were you even going to bring the souther
you're flying around everywhere you're
bringing huge cases of seltzer
everywhere you go didn't make any sense
Trump similar thing is like when he eats
Kentucky Fried Chicken or when he used
to on Trump's on Trump on an air Trump
on Trump's plane but that wasn't even
staged
that's real Trump doesn't know a healthy
meal he wouldn't know a healthy meal if
it forced itself down his throat but
that's his only connection to sort of
like average middle-class consumer
culture of the United staes just
completely unable to act like a normal
person because he's not and by the way
we know he's a germaphobe we have to
assume that right after the kids left
his desk was sanitized twice I mean
candy and kids touching your desk I
don't think that's gonna fly for a
germophobe like Trump bazaar and people
on our reddit discussion forum noticed
it you can join the discussion there at
david pakman.com slash re d di t back
after this